- [Evan] A subscriber,
Jay, wrote to me to tell me
that he wants to start a flower shop
and asked me how he could stand out.
Now, the flower industry is
brutal, ridiculously brutal.
Margins are being squeezed by supermarkets
and online stores.
There are fewer flower growers,
making it harder to find
locally grown products.
It's one of the most
competitive online businesses,
so good luck with getting people to search
and find your website.
When the economy is down,
luxury items like flowers
are the first thing people
stop spending money on.
The big refill partners
like funeral parlors
and banquet halls already have
long standing relationships with florists.
Man, who wants to be
in the flower business?
Jay did, so I was going to help him.
The secret was for Jay to realize
that he wasn't selling flowers.
He was selling something
much more powerful.
Jay was really selling calm.
What I learned from Jay
was that he loves flowers
because they make you feel calm.
If he's stressed or worried,
he looks at the flowers
and becomes calm.
That's his core.
For Jay to avoid massive
failure and beat the odds,
he needs to embrace calm.
And it's so much more than
just having great flowers.
His store should be a haven
for people who want to feel calm.
He should sell flowers
that make people calm.
He should have signage outside
that make people feel calm.
He should play music,
hire staff, greet people,
fill the air with scent,
and have a store layout
that makes people calm.
He should get involved with charities
that help people deal with
stress and overcoming trauma.
Talking with Jay or anyone on his team
should make you feel calm.
For him to be successful, he
needs others to experience
the calm feeling that he loves
getting from his flowers.
And it's easy to do.
It doesn't have to be fake.
It's not just a marketing strategy
because that's who Jay is.
He just needs to embrace it and share it.
Then, his flower shop
will become a destination
for people who want to be calm.
He'll attract people he'll
naturally get along with,
who will buy more
flowers, spend more money,
refer more customers,
and won't compare him
to the dozen roses you
can buy online for $19.99.
That's core selling, and
it applies to much more
than just selling.
It's a philosophy for how
you run your entire business
and your life.
Almost nobody does it,
and it's your chance
to dominate your industry.